It's okay if you're nervous.
You're always gonna fall sometimes.
You just have to keep trying.
First time I tried out for swim team,...
...I didn't make it, and I had to try really hard.
I was determined.
When I was in first grade, we had this poster that we had to fill out...
...and I wrote that I wanted to be an Olympian.
And that's how greatness is born.
It's an idea. It's hope.
It's years and years of dedication.
Doing your best at something you love.
I wanna be an Olympic medalist.
I wanna be an Olympic champion.
We all do.
That's the reason we run, is we wanna represent our country.
We wanna get a medal.
Nothing in life is handed to you.
You have to go out there and you have to fight and you have to work.
It doesn't matter if no one else believes in you.
Believe in yourself.
And that's true 'cause i know that anything is possible.
And even if it means that you will never go to the Olympics or you won't win,...
...everything that you've done on to that moment has made you who you are...
...and made you great.